[Applause]
but the big news is Fox News this week I
don't know if you've been following this
there they were going to be on trial
with Dominion voting systems Dominion of
the people who count the votes with
their vote and of course Fox News is
trying to sell their that Trump
really won the election so they said
well Fox the Dominion was in on it so
Dominion sued Fox News we were going to
see the trapna Fox News settled they
have to pay Dominion 787 million dollars
well
this way they avoided a trial and the
harrowing Prospect of having to swear to
tell the truth
that's what this was really about oh
and of course they had them dead to
rights because they had the texts
from the Fox News anchors on the air the
Fox News people were Towing the Trump
line behind the scenes they knew it was
and they were saying it the the
last row is last week Tucker Carlson
some of his new texts came out he called
Trump's lawyer Sidney Powell who he was
having on a show giving credibility to
and the text he says she's a
a psychopath a liar and a
and the Fox News spokesman said well
they are cherry picking those texts out
of context
I just want to know in what context is
a compliment that's just
my question
so Fox News did I put out a statement
after the this settlement was reached
they said this settlement reflects the
continuing commitment of Fox News to the
highest journalistic standards
say you know which news outlets have I
think even hired journalistic standards
the ones who don't have to pay three
quarters of a billion dollars
[Applause]